FIRST MEETING OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN FOR HUMAN SERVICES. I
WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME EVERYONE
AGAIN.
.
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
ALL OF YOU IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
TODAY'S HEARING WILL BE SHORT S.
BOTH.
SCHEDULED BILLS ARE ON CONSENT
CALENDAR.
FIRST YOU WILL NEED TO ESTABLISH
A QUORUM.
RUBIO HERE.
DOCTOR CHOI HERE BUT I'M GONNA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
RAYOS.
STONE.
THURMAN.
THANK YOU AND I SINCE WE DO HAVE
A QUORUM TO I AM WHICH INTO A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
HOW MOTION?
SECOND I'M MUCH OF THEM OF
MISTER JOHNSON BY MISTER CHOI.
UP.
SECRETARY CAN CALL THE VOLTAGE
REVIEW. I REVEAL AYE DUCKED
CHOI.
DOCTOR CHOI I HAVE I'M GONNA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE LESS.
STONE. STONE AYE THURMOND.
BERMAN I.
WHAT YOU NEED TO?
YEAH JUST GOING VIA EARLY.
AB SIX OH FIVE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MULLIN DO PASSED TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
RECOMMEND CONSENT AB NINE NINE
ONE PAIRS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BEARS DO PASSED
AS AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. BOOK
BILLS ARE UP FIVE TO ONE FIVE
ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH BOTH
BILLS ONLINE.
OPEN.
OF.
WE.
THANK YOU OUT WITH THAT I.
FOR DONE WE HAD A FARM AND.
WE CAN ADJOURN AT ELEVEN ARE
ONE THIRTY TWO.
THANK YOU.
I JUST WANT TO GO. TO THE AND.
I WOULD LIKE THAT.
OH OKAY.
I WAS
ZERO.
FROM THE HEAT HERE.
JEFF THANKS FOR ALL THE ADVICE
YOU GAVE.
WELL KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON
DEPICTED JUNE. I DON'T KNOW
THAT.
WE WILL NOT ALLOW ADAMS IN THE
NEXT FIFTEEN MINUTES
NINE NINE ONE.
MEMBER KRESS DO PASSED AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. AYE.
YEAH IT IS I.
ARAMBULA AYE.